yeah I was uh Michael invited me to
speak in this
back in the fall and this is just
another indication of how old I am I I
thought I was I just lecture in that
seminar didn't I and just this morning I
finally looked up and said it was 2010
so it was before you were here before
James was here when clemmer was on the
faculty here and other so and and none
of you heard me talk about that but it
was all about my work in autism as I've
been today's gonna be absolutely know of
well there's a small overlap within the
autism space but it plays a minor role
here let me tell you about what I'd like
to talk about I'm gonna quickly kind of
revisit the initial inspiring vision
that that James talked about mark
Weiser's definition and inspiration for
ubiquitous computing which is one of the
reasons why I shifted gears when I
became a faculty member at Georgia Tech
had moved more toward this style of
research and then I'll use that initial
kind of inspiration to motivate at an
area that I've been working on with a
number of colleagues for the last three
years now in an area I call
computational materials and I'll
demonstrate some examples I was going to
give some live demos here but because I
don't have enough shielding of my cables
and these podiums have a lot of
electrical wires you would just hear a
lot of 60 Hertz hum if I did the thing
so I can show things to people
afterwards if they're interested I'll
give five different examples of some
technologies that we've developed over
the last year and a half it turns out
and then returned to why these
technologies might be interested to give
you a flavor of some application ideas
and then round it out with some general
lessons talking about this work on a
multidisciplinary team that refers to
itself as cosmos so let's start by
revisiting wise there's original vision
and I sure hope with people in an HCI
seminar that you've read this article by
Mark Weiser if you haven't that's your
homework for tonight you can forget
everything I say and just read this
particular article but those that have
read it would recognize this as the very
first sentence and for extra credit and
free lunch can anyone tell me what the
very next line in that article was
they leave themselves into the fabric of
everyday life until they become
indistinguishable from it right that
Weiser meant this metaphorically at the
time his idea was that we're going to be
able to create these computational
devices in a variety of different shapes
and sizes and we'll have so many of them
that you will no longer consciously
think about is that a computer or not
and so they will vanish from your
consciousness in the same way that other
technologies like the electric motor or
like language and writing as
technologies have become so pervasive
that we don't think about them
consciously as technologies
so while Weiser meant that
metaphorically I think when you a really
good strategy particularly for students
when you're thinking about trying to
define a research agenda is go back a
few decades and look at visions from the
past and reinterpret them in today's
context so let's do that exercise here
and reinterpret what it might mean to
weave things weave themselves you know
profound technologies wise it was
referring to computing so how might we
weave computing into the fabric of
everyday life until they're
indistinguishable from it so that's the
kind of recasting of that idea and I'll
just throw a potentially silly idea out
there what would it mean if I could take
a post-it note write on it and put a
little button on there and put that on
my door when I leave and the
instructions say here please tap and
speak your message to Gregor you simply
tap that piece of paper and magically
but you can speak a message that's left
for Gregory so that's the kind of idea
of a computational capability that is
more like physical objects that we have
in our everyday world that might seem
fanciful but I'm hoping I'm going to
demonstrate to you that it really is not
that far-fetched given what we can do
today with various materials so I'm
going to use that motivation to talk
about what I'm calling computational
materials and I'm not going to define
the computational materials until the
end of the talk I'm going to define them
by giving you examples and then by
showing you how they might be used and
then
step back and talk about what I mean by
a computational material okay so one of
the problems of Wiser's vision as
prophetic as it was that we don't really
have ubiquitous computing we don't have
computing everywhere this has virtually
no computational capability this floor
has no computational capability that
podium it's it has some technologies
embedded within it but the surface there
is in no way a computational so we don't
really have computing throughout our
physical world in a way that wiser you
might interpret wise there's a vision to
be and why is that well I think there
are three problems with computing that
four that prevent it from being
ubiquitous and those become kind of the
driving design factors for computational
materials the first no secret to anyone
is power the more you want things to be
small and you want them to be mobile the
harder it is for them to be
computational in the sense that that
usually requires the consumption of
power so power is a big constraint no
secret to anyone who does wearable or
mobile computing cost despite what you
might think about the wonders of Moore's
law since the mid 60s - depending on
what charts you look at the end of last
decade or the middle of this current
decade it dramatically reduced the price
of the computing device a transistor but
it's nowhere near as cheap to produce
computing devices as it is to produce
other kinds of artifacts that we have in
our everyday life like the fibers in
that car but carpet or the drywall or
paper or even glass we have or gasoline
or molecules chemicals that we use in
medical those are much cheaper to
manufacture largely because they take a
different approach to manufacturing
they're less about tightly integrated
processes that all have to be perfect in
order to get a good output and they take
more the notion of let's use chemical
engineering techniques to manufacture a
large number of things and then use
other properties to filter out the
objects and have the property
that we want which is a different way of
thinking about manufacturing then has
existed and then what underpins a
Moore's law which is better and better
more complex integrated manufacturing
processes so cost is an issue and
probably most importantly is form factor
you can probably identify something
that's computational because it looks
like a computer looks like a an
integrated circuit chip you can
recognize them this doesn't look like a
computer to you and so you don't think
it is a computer so how do we create
form factors of computational things
that look more like everyday objects or
by attaching them to everyday objects
they don't change the look of those
objects themselves so let's take those
three factors and use those as kind of
driving design goals for a new kind of
technology that we want to be able to
create or invent right we want to never
have to change a battery and I would say
beyond that and we don't have the luxury
of plugging in to power we want it to be
cheap to produce at large scale so as
cheap as it is to produce drywall or
reams of paper and the form factor they
should look like everyday materials or
if you attach them to existing everyday
materials don't change what those
materials look like or even how they
behave from a physical perspective so
how do we get there I think one of the
ways we get there is we have to think
differently about what a computing
device is and we shouldn't be shackled
by assumptions about what the measures
of success for computing should be it's
not always the case that you advance
yourself by thinking about from Moore's
Law perspective that things should
always be cheaper and smaller and I can
package them in a different kinds of
packages or smaller packages it also
shouldn't be the case that in order to
communicate do wireless communication
the measure of success is that I can
either shoot it further or I can I can
send more at once those aren't always
the measures of success that leads you
to the more creative kinds of ideas I'm
gonna come back to this idea at the very
end but the other thing is to seek
influence from and this is talking to
designers and computer scientists seek
in
from disciplines that we don't
necessarily seek influence from today
and I'll show you some examples of
influence from material science from
organic electronics from thinking about
nano manufacturing of high-performance
devices electrochemistry and advanced
additive manufacturing techniques so now
computation of materials let me give you
some examples of what I consider to be a
new way of thinking about what a
computer is and I'm gonna give you five
examples I won't talk about the one down
at the bottom unless someone is
interested in it so I'll jump right into
these five different examples some of
them have some videos some of them have
some props I can talk about and we'll
see how time what time lets me do so the
first one is a project called
a Saturn and the idea here is we want to
produce an acoustic or vibration sensor
but we want to be self sustainable in
the sense that it doesn't require well
the power source it requires is the
phenomenon that it's sensing in this
case the sound or vibration so generate
energy from those things so that in that
sense it's self sustainable but it also
has to be made of relatively simple
materials with relatively simple
manufacturing processes and as such it
could then be easy to deploy so you'll
see an example here of one of our
prototype Saturn patches that's a thin
and flexible multi-layer material now
how does this work so this is where we
get a little inspiration from material
science folks anyone here unlike James
and me and actually has long enough hair
that when you take a plastic comb
through your hair and you move the comb
come away from it what happens the hair
comes with you right but because there's
an exchange of charge between the two
yeah okay you wait a couple years
Michael the there's an exchange of
charges between the plastic of the comb
and the hair in this case that's a dog's
hair or human hair and so it turns out
any two materials demonstrate this
exchange of charged property but certain
pairs of materials are so far apart in
terms of their desire to attract a
positive charge or a negative charge
when they come in contact with another
one that if you take ones that are far
enough apart
you can actually take advantage of that
electrostatic field that gets bit that
gets built up so in this case we've got
hair and the floral polymer that's the
plastic in the comb now let me give you
a quick tutorial on how you can harvest
this phenomenon to produce an
alternating current
so in this Saturn project I've got the
prototype right here it's mounted in
this wood frame there are four layers
you got paper on the top this is the
paper the paper has a pattern of holes
in it for reasons I'll explain later if
at all and then it's coated with copper
and then there's a plastic PTFE and this
this one has a different plastic pef go
to fluoropolymer and it also has copper
on its one side what we're interested in
is the relationship between the copper
on the top and the plastic on the bottom
there and what happens when they come in
contact and separate so when they come
together there is an upon separation
there's an exchange of charge between
the copper and the plastic the copper
getting the positive charge and the PTFE
or the floral polymer getting the
negative charge when you separate them
you now have an electric charge electric
field between those two surfaces if you
provide a way for the positive charge on
that copper to flow you could balance
that electric charge that's why we have
the copper on the on the bottom of the
of the PTFE so if we connect those two
electrodes we provide a path to balance
the electric field if we continue to do
that what results this combination of
the tribal electric exchange of charge
and the electrostatic induction that is
the balancing of those charge you
continue to do that this is what's
called a tribal electric nano generator
which was invented by my colleague of zo
Wang at Georgia Tech in material science
so that inspired us to think how might
we take advantage of that charge by
introducing a vibrational source that
can then reproduce some signal that you
might that might be meaningful and a
good vibrating source is human the human
voice so if you design this multi-layer
material appropriately
you can enhance the micro vibrations
between the copper and the plastic and
you can essentially produce an
alternating current the amplitude of
which mimics the amplitude of the voice
so you have a sensor an acoustic sensor
that doesn't require any external power
other than the power of the signal it's
trying to interpret so your voice
provides the energy I was going to show
you a demo but we have unshielded wires
here but with this particular device I
can sit it here and I can stand back
here and I can speak in my regular voice
and you would hear the the signal that's
retrieved from this would it would
reproduce reproduce my voice if you
don't believe me we can set it up
outside it it is just outside before and
we'll show you what it looks like I can
do it here but it would sound like 60
Hertz hum which is not well it's not
entirely unlike my voice but it's not
exactly my voice I won't show this
particular demo because I got a lot of
different things to to talk to you about
and we'll come back later if people want
to see particular demos here one of the
things you could do with this rather
than just recording voice is you can say
well is it possible that you can
generate enough energy here that you
could do more than just record the
signal so if you have enough incident
sound in terms of its amplitude incident
on this particular patch can you produce
enough energy that would allow you to do
something computational in this case the
simplest thing is could you flip a bit
in in flash memory and the paper that
this is about which I'll show I think
was on the earlier slide demonstrates
the calculation to show that you
actually can produce enough energy to
flip a bit and that's interesting
because that means that you can place it
in an environment and it can record
whether sound levels went over some
particular threshold and there are lots
of military and non-military
applications of something like that but
that I just showed you that Saturn is
just an acoustic sensor right so in and
of itself and not all that interesting
is not much you can do with it I showed
one simple thing you could do is you
could flip a bit maybe you can generate
enough and
you do some other things but you
typically can't generate enough energy
to wirelessly transmit some information
so to do that you need to use another
trick for a passive communication and
this is not something we invented but as
is known in the literature of passive
forms of wireless communication that use
the backscatter phenomenon of radio
frequency so if you attach an antenna to
this patch and put a simple transistor a
jfet transistor between the patch and
the antenna then you can modulate the
reflected RF signal and that modulated
signal can essentially amplitude
modulation can reproduce the acoustic
signal that was received that's incident
upon the patch and communicated
wirelessly over some distance so just to
show you very quickly what that means
this is a demo that was just done we
presented our work Zuse the zero energy
ubiquitous sound sensing surface our
setup consists of an RF transmitter
receiver and zeus patch placed at a
distance the transmitter broadcasts a
carrier wave at 915 megahertz which has
received an amplitude modulated by the
zeus patch in the presence of slight
vibrations like speech or touch the
modulated signal is back scattered to
the receiver and the audio information
captured by the patch is extracted let's
look at an example high standpoint this
is demonstration for Zeus zero energy
you look at the sound sensing surface
[Music]
that's the raw signal you can do some
processes to clean up some of that noise
but that's just a raw signal that was
actually recorded just last night um so
let's go on to another example so that's
an example of a thin flexible
multi-layer material that has the
ability to record vibration and with
additional technology can communicate
that information over some distance so
let's take that same idea of the
triboelectric nano generator and use of
different form factor this is something
this will be presented at the chi
conference in a month or two this is a
series of layers of silicon and
conductive thread that are wrapped in a
coil around the silicon and you've got
three different ways tribal electric
interaction happens here fingers can
touch the silicon and exchange charge so
you can you could produce a charge with
that movement and deforming it will
cause a certain kind of change so this
quick video here will talk a little bit
about what this is used for we introduce
serpentine a self-powered reversibly
deformable cord sensor using principles
of tribal Electric nano generators
serpentine senses mechanical
deformations without an external power
source
serpentine can detect six unique human
interactions pluck 12 stretch pinch
Whittle and twist
serpentine can be integrated into
applications like a hoody string as a
music controller and a slingshot as a
game controller okay so those are two
examples of what out refer to as a
self-sustainable sensor it uses the
phenomenon that it's trying to sense
vibration or sound or the manipulation
or deformation of a chord as the source
of energy and and both use the same
phenomenon tribo electric nano
generation yes James your applications
where job need to do some communication
like what I've been showing these is as
sensors you're talking about what I
might do to use these simply as
harvesters to do other things and that's
actually the way you want to start to
think about these things they don't have
to be sensors they can be harvesters if
they're in the presence of the
phenomenon so for example talk a little
bit about this when I communicate with
RFID I could already harvest RFID energy
to run a traditional microphone or other
sensor rather
yeah it's love it's also much cheaper
simpler materials and a form factor I
think yes and I'll come to a series of
those kinds of applications but it's
it's not just an application that you
couldn't otherwise do with conventional
ones but the fact that you can actually
do it at much larger scale with with
these solutions is one of the ways to
think about that but it's a good kind of
a challenge to be thinking about but the
general sensing is how can you identify
a phenomenon that you want to sense and
use that phenomenon as the means of
powering the way you're going to sense
and potentially compute actuate or
communicate the information after that
so what are some other examples I'm
going to show you this first one
detecting water that's a project that's
currently in progress things that
haven't been explored yet but I think
can work with the same idea is how might
you detect ammonia which is sometimes an
indicator of spoilage of food and how
might you detect smoke so and I'll talk
roughly about what this means about
being able to produce easily deployed
battery-free sensors in a variety of
different places that you can't do that
easily today so let's take the example
of water so how do we design a sensor
that will generate power in the presence
of water and use that power to do
something in this case we're gonna use
the power to communicate to identify
water is here but you could do other
things as well
so we're gonna use the power for
wireless communication and on top of
that you got to make it durable and you
got to make it easy to deploy in the
places where you want to detect water
leakage so for example in talking to a
construction folks roofs our places
where we want to detect leaks and
basements our places where we want to
detect leaks and we want to be able to
do it in the process of building those
environments or by adding it as a
retrofit so battery 101 I apologize to
those who probably know way more than I
do about this electrochemistry this is
very simple but a battery essentially
has a cathode and an anode and
uses an electrolyte between those two to
essentially cause some kind of chemical
reaction that induces the flow of charge
from one end to the other one you when
you put a load across the anode in the
cathode so in the presence in the
absence of electrolyte it's it's inert
nothing happens but when you have the
electrolyte then the battery is engaged
so the idea here is how can we build a
battery as a thin material that when it
gets in the presence of something that
acts as an electrolyte will activate the
battery that's the very simple idea and
here's an initial kind of demonstration
of this capability that's just a simple
prototype that we built a month or two
ago it's aluminum foil with a number of
with something laid on the on one side
of the aluminum a plastic mesh that
separate separates that layer from the
layer on the bottom that has a different
chemical that's sprayed onto it that
will give you the cathode and anode
effect it's got holes in it it's
perforated which means when water comes
to one side it will soak between the two
layers and produce power because it's
activated the chemical reaction it's
produced the the electrolyte so a very
simple idea to allow us to produce this
kind of water activated battery connect
that to it produces enough power to
power a standard ble beacon or you could
have a printed specialized wireless
communication that that it will do and
we have demonstrations of this and we're
further characterizing that now and
you'll read this soon and some Journal
of choice in the future now I'm going to
talk about another example of some work
in progress and this is how do we
produce surfaces that are cheap to
produce their paper like and can provide
interactive capabilities and the
interactive capability we're going to
introduce now is just being able to
detect where you touch on that surface
so imagine an N by M grid and I can
determine when I touch anywhere on one
of those cells but I can also swipe
across here and get a series of touches
and wirelessly communicate that
information so that it can then cause
something to happen somewhere in the
world
so I'll show a quick video here that
demonstrates these particular features
of how it works and I'll describe what's
not clear there's very interesting so
those are some of the parameters for
what you're trying to do here and we'll
have something like a cat whisker that
you'll see that's using FM ambient
backscatter in order to be able to
communicate this is just a simple
printed surface so that's the schematic
of it now you'll see the crufty looking
prototype FM ambient FM and using the FM
receiver on a smart phone to communicate
so there's the crufty prototype the
little touch surface the simple
circuitry
on a breadboard the power harvesting so
this is operating at less than 100 micro
watts of power and then the smart phone
that is the FM receiver of the
backscatter now you'll see an on my
student walk up touch somewhere here and
you there's nuts a great contrast but
you'll see little X appear where it's
indicated where he's touching alright
you've got about a 400 millisecond
latency unfortunately didn't this one
drag after it there's no latency after
the first one is detected so you can
drag across there and see those X's move
around okay so that's you know we'll get
to these ideas of how you might use this
so that's a series of different kinds of
computation of materials that are either
self sustained while they're
self-sustaining in the sense that they
either use the phenomenon that they're
sensing to generate the power or they
run at such low power that commodity
harvesting techniques are enough to be
able to power them in normal ambient
indoor settings so let's think about
applications because as wives are taught
us the only reason you should be
interested in these new technologies is
the extent to which they allow you to do
interesting things from our from our
human experience and
I'm gonna talk about this and there are
many more ideas than what I'm going to
show you here but I like to think about
them in a number of different kinds of
categories the first is disposable by
which we mean that if you can make these
things cheap enough and with materials
that it's responsible enough to throw
away or recycle and they're not toxic
then what are some scenarios that allow
you to think about disposable
applications of computational material
or you might think about well I want
these things to be around for a while so
it's not disposable but I want to make
it very easy to deploy them wherever I
want them to be and slightly related to
easily deployed is some level of
convenience that they convey and what
I'll try to demonstrate here is that
because you can make these materials
fairly thin and lightweight you can do
certain things that with things that are
easier to carry around on your body
around with you then you can with
conventional technologies and then the
last category as well now I want to put
these things somewhere where I'm not
going to be able to get access to them
very easily and they need to be around
for decades
so enduring case studies so the first
one was the what if that I gave you at
the very beginning so I hope you see the
path from what I've already demonstrated
what things that we've already published
this kind of thin multi material
wirelessly transmitting material that
leads us in the direction toward the
post-it note that you tap and then can
record a message but simply translate
that are transmitted that voice message
somewhere else
another scenario along these lines how
many people here have an audio or a
voice home assistant right how many do
you have in your house raise your hand
how many do you have in your house that
was a bad way to say how many have more
than one in your house
okay how many have bought an additional
one because you wanted to have a more
conveniently accessible for where you
wanted to say things right so what if
instead of buying another echo dot or
Google assistant or whatever you want to
call it you could instead take a piece
of paper and place it in your closet
where you get dressed in the morning and
want to know what the weather is and
that becomes a remote microphone to
alexa or goo
or whatever right so a way of providing
a remote microphone to a service that
you can deploy in other places very very
easy very simply this is not far off
from what we're talking about here let's
take this case of and that's an example
of ease of deployment as well as a
potentially disposable because maybe you
don't want the microphone there all the
time
but in the case of easily deployed let's
think about the case of battery free
sensors so here's an example of a
vibration detector that plays the role
of determining whether glass has been
broken and you can see here it's fairly
bulky that little box that's attached to
the window and it's wired to some
security infrastructure so that an alarm
can be struck so not the kind of thing
that would be easy to deploy in a home
but if you instead and remember I told
you about the the ability with these
current patches that size of being able
to harvest enough energy to flip a bit
right or harvest enough energy to the
flip a bit and communicate that bit of
information so here we could take a
little patch put it on the window
breaking of the glass produces enough
energy that will cause that patch to be
able to communicate hey something
happened here we went over a threshold
likely the glass is broken so that's one
example of a conventional glass break
detector being replaced with that Zeus
like technology the self-sustainable
water sensor is an example that one I
showed you the original prototype you
can bend that you could put some
adhesion on it you could wrap that
around the pipe put that under a sink
you could put that in building material
under the the roof or in the basement
and as long as you could isolate the
different patches you could enable them
to communicate Oh water here and by the
way I'm patch 247 I'm located in your
basement right there's some programming
that goes along with that but we have
the opportunity to deploy these kinds of
water sensors but could you do this also
for smoke I'm pretty sure you can can
you do this first spoil food I talked
about ammonia I'm pretty sure you can
the question is can we manufacture these
at scale
so they're they're very cheap to be able
to deploy another example of this ez
deploy what we have up there at the top
is an example of a in-car control of the
media system so what if I could
essentially produce a piece of paper
that has those same symbols on it put
that on the side of the the door in the
backseat of the car and now someone
could touch there and essentially
remotely control the particular
capabilities of that media system well
what I showed you with that battery-free
touch interface is that was using
ambient FM and need an FM receiver
well most cars are in the presence of a
reasonably good FM signal that's why we
use the FM radio and they have an FM
receiver in there so it's possible to be
able to deploy something like this
inside of a car
another example here I talked about
using this post-it note as a remote
microphone but maybe it could be one of
those here are the things I want to be
able to do order new toothpaste now put
that in the in the cupboard of in my by
my vanity when I know when the
toothpaste has run out so I can just
simply tap right there and have those
kinds of lists that I that I that I
could produce another use case that
maybe is a little more compelling how
many of you have traveled in a major
airport in the last year and a half ok
have you walked into a restroom and
walked out of that restroom and noticed
a panel that looks something like this
you click a button here to indicate
whether that whole restroom is makes you
happy sad or neutral is there a problem
with it I think is what they're trying
to communicate well let's imagine
instead we can attach a sticker to any
of those particular items so here is a
light switch there's a thermometer or
thermostat and you have these little
stickers that if you tap it that will
send a message that that particular
device needs servicing so take the case
of the restroom now instead of
expressing your impression of the entire
restroom you could say that soap
dispensers not working that towel
dispensers not working that toilet is
not working or this wall is dirty you
could have these kinds of stickers and
and tapping whether it's a simple tap or
some rhythm that you need to tap you can
provide that kind of feedback and this
is only interesting if it's easy to
deploy these kinds of stickers
everywhere and easily map their the
meaning of interacting with them to what
message gets sent and provide the
infrastructure for that wireless
communication to occur but I think these
things are realizable something I didn't
show you was some work we've been doing
in combination of printed organics of
combining harvesting materials with
sensing materials to provide thin
flexible surfaces that can act as depth
imagers or a multi-touch surface and
they are self-sustaining and that the
harvesting layer produces enough energy
for the you don't need to produce as
much energy for the sensing to work but
you need to produce energy for that
depth image to be communicated somewhere
else now imagine the tiles in the
ceiling in this office in this
conference room had those kinds of depth
sensors on them so now you have a
ceiling that's easily the deployed that
could do depth imaging of a volume below
it this is one particular example that
but there are lots of examples were
getting 3d imaging of a volume of space
by easily deploying either things in the
ceiling or on the walls might be of some
value let's talk a little bit about
convenience so I said I was last here in
2010 and what I talked about was
technology and autism because as some of
you may know I have two boys on the
autism spectrum the oldest of which is a
non-speaking individual and fortunately
I've worked with him hard enough over
the last couple years that he's now able
to communicate by tapping on a keyboard
but that requires the communication
partner and it requires that
communication partner to hold something
so initially what I held was a laminated
board and my son Aidan could tap out
letters on there to indicate that he
understands what's being spoken to him
or make a particular request and then I
would write down on a piece of paper so
he advanced to the point where I could
hold a light wireless keyboard and he
would tap the key and it would
communicate the information to my phone
and that prevented me from having to
write it also makes my right shoulder
extremely sore because those light
wireless keyboards are not so
light when you hold them for an hour
with an individual so if I could go back
to the laminated board and turn that
into a wireless keyboard that would be
much more convenient for me that's
possible with that battery free touch
surface that I talked about before
another example imagine I have a door
that has an automatic lock on it and I
have an app on my phone that allows me
to essentially unlock it by doing
whatever typing a pin or doing some
imaging of a some biometric now what if
I could place next to that door a little
piece of paper and on that paper is
essentially a pad and I tap the code and
that will send a signal that will open
that door okay this is like the remote
control interface I talked about in the
car that interface can be in a variety
of places it doesn't have to be next to
the door it can be anywhere that I want
it to be the last example I'm going to
show you is looking at the enduring use
case and I hope this tries to address a
little about what you were saying James
in terms of why you wouldn't do this
necessarily with conventional silicon
based technologies because of their
rigidity so in a lot of industrial
settings you have industrial carpet it's
typically tiles of carpet you could you
probably see if you look here but
interface is one of the I think it's the
the second largest manufacturer of
industrial carpet they have tiles that
you place down and they have a product
they've had for over a decade now where
they put RFID tags in the carpet tiles
so that when the carpet is cleaned you
can have a recording and evidence that
the carpet was cleaned in some settings
that's an important piece of information
to do how do they do that well the big
industrial cleaners have an rfid reader
on them and so as it goes over it reads
the the tags and it reports where it has
been but what if I want to record
something that doesn't have an RFID
reader on it or very close to the tag
like a person walking over the tile so
take something like this material which
just detects a pressure my footstep now
can
enough energy to communicate out Oh this
tile has been stepped on so now the
carpet can track a human foot traffic
over a particular space which is
interesting on a number of different
dimensions but let's take that one step
further because what's interesting about
what I described is that with carpet you
could do this and you would have
anonymous tracking of where people are
but let's think about a situation where
you might want to actually know who is
walking so I mentioned I have two boys
on the spectrum the younger one was the
runner in the family and would go to
whenever we went to new places we would
lose him and you might smile at that but
when you lose a child at Disneyworld or
a big mall for an hour and he can't
communicate effectively that's a little
harrowing so in addition to now there's
two things interesting about this
particular scenario because in most
malls they're not carpeted so now I'm
thinking how could you introduce this
kind of tribal electric effect in floor
materials like concrete or linoleum
those kinds of materials that's the
interesting case in addition to carpet
but now let's use technologies like we
had here this is a cylindrical cord but
it doesn't have to be that form factor
what if that was an insole in your shoe
and stepping on it produced enough
energy to say who was it was stepping
there so now I have the the floor that
says I've been stepped on and a shoe
that says oh by the way it was Gregory
so now I might put that in the insole of
my child or if I want to choose to put
that in it as an opt-in strategy I now
can track who was walking in particular
places last example I'll give you which
I've already foreshadowed is this notion
of you see on the left there we produce
huge amounts of these materials like
Tyvek companies like DuPont or 3m
produce these kinds of materials and
they produce them on the at the rate of
about eight square meters a second is
how fast tech can be produced and that's
or wrap around a building to be a wind
barrier and a water barrier but not a
sensor so what if you could add the
capability in addition to trying to be
a wind barrier and a water barrier it
could indicate when it actually had to
be a water barrier there is a leak from
from coming outside it now you might say
why would people want to do that at
Georgia Tech and I'm sure well is there
a building here on campus that has a
roof garden California you guys would
have a I mean don't tell me we
Atlantians are more hip than you Silicon
Valley folks but you know this isn't
being recorded but just between you and
me we may be so one of our new buildings
on campus has a roof garden and when
they built that roof garden they were
very concerned about leaking because you
know they were gonna be watering things
up there irrigating the life that that's
up there so they created a very
intricate series of conductive rows and
columns underneath that roof garden and
everyday somewhat I don't know if it's
everyday or not but occasionally someone
goes with a little sensor and basically
walks along the upper floor to see are
there any leaks underneath this
particular building okay so there are
applications in which that being able to
produce an easy to deploy cheaper active
form of water detection has some value
all right so this is good I have only a
few more things to say and we have some
time for you guys to comment so I'm
going to leave you with a couple of
general lessons one of the ways I look
at the world is in terms of generational
shifts in technology so this particular
paper talks about four generations of
technologies in you know the first three
are ones that others have mentioned I
just kind of regurgitate that so that
third generation that was Wiser's vision
of ubiquitous computing different scales
of technology and I noticed a few years
ago that in the 2000s there were a
number of interesting technologies that
I cleverly named cloudcrowd shroud and
allowed because that rhymes with a bout
that's not why I did it but it does
rhyme with my last name and it's for
technologies into the fourth generation
by the way I am foreshadowing the fifth
generation and how many examples did I
give you total coincidence so those are
technologies that really you could argue
Weiser did not foresee and they have
dominated how we think about I mean a
lot of the work that Michael
thus takes advantage of crowd as a
programmable entity and these are things
that are just bread and butter of how we
think about what makes things
interesting what I proposed here were
five different tech not examples of
computational material techniques and
that is what I consider to be a fifth
generation potential fifth generation of
technologies of computational materials
so what do I say a computational
material is it's a material that can
harvest the power to do the things that
a computer does it could store
information it could compute logical
operations it could sense I showed you
lots of examples of sensing I didn't
show you any examples of actuation but
stay tuned it can communicate within and
between materials and in addition and
this is probably the top part that it
harvests the power is what's important
in this bottom part that they're
manufactured in large quantities at low
cost and are used in everyday life to do
interesting things so those are
computational materials second point I
want to put here is about thinking
differently about how we can create a
vision or realization of ubiquitous
computing that Weiser first foreshadowed
if you are driven by Moore's law you
think in terms of computers always
getting smaller always getting cheaper
and always getting more powerful and
that has been a phenomenal creative
insight for people that for decades
drove how we thought in particular as
researchers about what we would want to
create for the future we could create
bulky near but not quite real-time
demonstrations of things and Moore's law
would take care of some of those things
in a couple years it would work it would
be cheaper to be smaller it would run in
real time we didn't have to worry about
that it just happened so we envision
things that were bulky that ultimately
would not be bulky that were expensive
that ultimately would not be expensive
that didn't quite run as fast as we
would want but would run as fast as we
want for the most part we can't always
live in that world anymore but there's
another way to think creatively and
that's to think that well these
computational materials these self
sustainable materials are always going
to get larger scale
meaning it'll be cheaper to produce them
in mass quantities and they'll become as
a result will become more available we
can put them in lots more situations so
that's the second thought the third
thought is how do you get there well and
here I'm talking mostly to the students
because your minds are still open to
learning new things though you get to my
age and you tend to resist wanting to
learn new things so James has just a
couple more years before he will stop
wanting to think about new things but
the way we got to a lot of these
prototypes is by consulting experts in
material science Chemical Engineering
Electrical Engineering which we as
computer scientists have a reasonable
relationship computer architecture and
design or HCI you need to think more
deeply about the materials and how
they're manufactured to be creative if
you care about the vision of these
computational materials and of course
I'm showing you some of my colleagues at
Georgia Tech who fall into those
different categories and together we
form the Kosmos team which used to stand
for something but because it's so
important we don't care about the
acronym anymore we just care about the
the vision and the inspiration of Cosmos
you know we're reaching for the stars
but as we all know these are the people
that actually did all the work and these
are the people that take all the credit
right last note I'm going to provide for
you is that these computation and
materials these simple things that I
demonstrated you by themselves are not
that impressive it only becomes
impressive if you can manufacture and
deploy them at large scale and then I
think something truly amazing can happen
possibly truely whirring as well so what
I think we're on the cusp of is an
alternative to our standard computing
industry and the question is how is it
going to emerge is it going to be the
Intel's of the world that will decide to
create different kinds of computational
devices or will it be the DuPont's and
the Corning's of the world that
manufacture Goods and are familiar with
these mass production is that oh we want
our goods to be computational or is it
going to be some young whippersnapper or
a few who is going to have a
a great idea and she will produce an
example of a computational material that
will take off and will overtake the
apples and Facebook's and Google's of
the world interesting but I think it
might happen in the next five to ten
years so with that I will thank you
[Applause]